สวัสดีค่ะครูนิกสวัสดีครับครูหญิงแล้วก็
สวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนด้วยนะครับสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนออเดี๋ยวเรามาเขียนวันที่ก่อนนะ
คะได้ได้เดี๋ยวขอแชร์แชร์สกรีนแป๊บนึงนะ
คะนักเรียนอ่ะครูนี้คะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวัน
นี้ครับ
วันพฤหัสอที่อเมริกัน
นะแป๊บนึงนะคะเอ่ออ่ะเออก็เขียนอย่างี้
ได้นี่นา
อ่าวันพฤหัสบนะคะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 3
ครับเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤศจิกายนครับปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ 25  5  65
ครับค่ะปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ 20  22 ครับค่ะ
ตอนนี้ที่
อเมริกาเวลากี่โมงแล้วคะตอนนี้นะครับเวลา
194 น
อื 194 นของครูนิกก็เป็นเวลากลางคืนใช่
ใช่
อืแล้วตอนนี้ที่ไทยกี่โมงครับที่ไทยเนี่ย
นะคะตอนนี้ 7 น 4 นนะคะเป็นเวลาตอนเช้า
แล้วก็อที่ไทยเนี่ยวันศุกร์แล้วครูนิกอ๋อ
วันศุกร์แล้วใช่วันที่ 4 ตอนนี้นะคะครู
นิกกับครูหญิงอยู่คนละวันอยู่คนละวัน
ใช่
ครับโอเคค่ะก็ครูนิกสบายดีนะคะสบายดีครับ
ก็ครูนิกเพิ่งเพิ่งทำงานเสร็จแล้วก็กลับ
มาที่บ้านเมื่อครึ่งชั่วโมงที่แล้วแล้วก็
กินข้าวกินข้าวแล้วก็อ้าได้เวลาพอดีก็เลย
มาเจอครูหญิงได้ค่ะของครูหญิงก็เพิ่งตื่น
ครึ่งชั่วโมงที่แล้วโอแต่ครูหญิงตื่นเช้า
เนาะใช่ตื่นเช้าได้ค่ะตื่นได้ตื่นเช้าได้
แปลว่าปกติไม่ค่อยตื่นเช้าไม่ค่อยไม่คอย
ปกติเนี่ย
ตื่นประมาณ 800 นอ่ะคุณหญิงจะตื่นประมาณ
8:00
นครับแต่ว่า 18:30 นก็โอเคนะคะครูนิกปิ
ไม่แย่ของครูนิกเนี่ยปกติก็จะประมาณ 7:00
น
อืใช่คนี้ก็ตื่นเช้าอยู่นะคือเหมือนมัน
ชินแล้วมันชินไปแล้วเพราะว่าค่ะเมื่อก่อน
เนี่ย 99:00 นแต่อตอนนี้เนี่ยมันไม่ได้
นอนคนเดียวแล้วเพราะว่านอนกับแฟนแล้วแฟน
คุณนิกเตื่นเช้าแฟนคุณนิกตื่น 18:00
น
โหเช้ามากใช่ไม่เพราะว่าเค้าต้องไปทำงาน
ครับค่ะเตั้งแต่ก็เลยอืเออเนาะธรรมดานะ
เราไปทำงานเราก็แบบตื่นเช้าเพราะว่าต้อง
อาบน้ำแต่งตัวแล้วก็ขับรถไปทำงานอีกอืใช่
นั่นแหละครับได้ค่ะก็วันนี้นะคะครูหญิง
เนี่ยมาเจอครูนิกก็มีเกมมาเล่นกับครูนิก
นะคะโอเคอืเกมอะไรครับครูหญิงจะ
มีคำ
ถามแล้วก็มีให้ครูนิกเลือกเนี่ย A
หรือ
B ครับอืนะคะครูนิกต้องคิดว่าเอ๊ครูนิก
จะเลือกอะไรมากกว่ากันโอเคคุอาจจะอยาก
เลือกทั้ง 2 อย่างหรือว่าไม่อยากเลือก
ทั้ง 2 อย่างแต่คนนิคิดว่าเอ๊ได้ใช่มอะไร
นะคือถ้าเกิดว่าคุนิกไม่อยากเลือก 2
อย่างก็ได้หรอไม่ได้ค่ะครูนิไม่อยากเลือก
2 อย่างครูนิก็ต้องต้องคิดว่าอันนี้ก็
ไม่อยากได้อันนี้ก็ไม่อยากเลือกอันนี้ก็
ไม่อยากเลือกอันนี้ก็ไม่อยากเลือกแต่ถ้า
ต้องเลือกจะเลือกอะไรมากกว่ากันออโอเคอ
ได้ครับโอเคได้ๆๆค่ะงั้นเดี๋ยวเอาเอาคำ
ถามที่เราต้องใช้กระดานเลยดีกว่านะคะข้อ
แรกนะคะครูนิกครูนิกจะเลือกอะไรมากกว่า
กัน
ระหว่างให้มีฤดูร
ร้อนอันนี้เนาะฤดูร้อนนะ
คะฤดู
ร้อนมีฤดูร้อนถ้าฤดูร้อนที่อเมริกานี่
เดือนอะไรอ่ะคะกูนิกของคุณนิกคิดว่าน่าจะ
เดือนมิถุนายนนะครับมิถุนายนก็คือดที่ 6
ใช่ค่ะอืจนถึงกันยา
นะครับประมาณนั้นอ่าประมาณใช่มั้ยคะก็อัน
แรกเนี่ยก็คือให้มีฤดูร้อนเนี่ยมากขึ้น
อาจจะถึงประมาณสักเดือนตุลาคมก็ได้อ่า
เพิ่มอีก 1 เดือนหรือครูนิกอยากจะให้มี
ฤดู
หนาวเนาฤดูหนาวเริ่มเดือนอะไรหรอคะครูนิก
ที่นี่ครับฤดูหนาวเนี่ยจะเริ่ม
คิดว่าจะเริ่มธันวาคม
อื
ใช่ธันวาคมแล้วก็ยาวไปถึงมีนาคมอือ่าอคือ
เมืองที่ิกอยู่นะครับค่ะเมืองครูนิกเนาะ
ก็ให้ไปถึงเมษายนอย่างเงี้ยเพิ่มไปอีก 1
เดือนครูนิกจะเลือกอะไรระหว่างให้มีฤดูร
ร้อนนานขึ้นหรือว่ามีฤดูหนาวนานขึ้นคครู
นิกอยากได้อะไรมากกว่า
กันอันนี้เนี่ยระหว่างฤดูร้อนกับฤดู
หนาวเลือกง่ายมากครูนิกจะเลือกให้มีฤดู
หนาวมากกว่า
ออเลือกอันนี้ใช่มคะทำไมอ่ะทำไมครูนิก
เนี่ยชอบอากาศหนาวอยู่แล้วแล้วค่ะใช่แล้ว
ก็คุณนิอชอบแต่งตัว
ออห้ะโทษ
ครับเห็นูประกาศหนาวก็เลยจเอ้าถ้าครูนิก
ชอบแต่งตัวฤดูร้อนเนี่ยมันไม่แต่งตัวได้
มากกว่าเหรอคะแบบโอ้อันนี้มีเสื้อโอ๊ะวัน
นี้อยากจะทำแบบนี้ฤดูหนาวเนี่ยมันต้องใส่
เสื้อใส่เสื้อใส่เสื้อหลายๆ
ชั้นก็สำหรับครูนิกเนี่ยครูนิกคิดว่าฤดู
หนาวเนี่ยใส่เสื้อหลายชั้นใช่แต่มันก็
เหมือนกับเพิ่มเหมือนกับใส่เสื้อปกติแล้ว
ก็มีใส่แจ็คเก็ตอที่เป็นอีกสีนึงหรือใส่
ถุงเท้าครับรองเท้าค่ะใช่อืหรือว่าอ้า
อยู่ไหนลคะเนี่ยเนี่ยปากกาแล้วก็ใส่ถุง
มือใช่ใชใส่ถุง
เท้าเดี๋ยวใส่ถุงมือคุณนิกเดี๋ยวคุณนิกมา
แป๊บนึงพอดีไฟมัน
ได้ได้ค่ะอ่าเนาะหรือว่าพุนี้อาจะมีหมวก
อืใช่แบบนั้นน่ะอ่าคุณนีก็เลยคิดว่าอัน
นี้มันคือแบบเป็นการแต่งตัว
ที่เราจะคิดใช่มยเอ๊วันนี้เราอยากจะใส่
หมวกอะไรดีน้าใส่ถุงมืออก็เลยเลือกฤดู
หนาวนะคะให้มีฤดูหนาวมาก
ขึ้นเพราะสำหรับครูนิกเนี่ยครูนิกคิดว่า
ถ้าฤดูร้อนมันแต่งตัวมันแต่งตัวยากสำหรับ
ครูนิกนะเพราะพออากาศมันร้อนมากเนี่ยเรา
ก็ไม่อยากใส่เสื้อเออเนาะเราก็จะใส่แค่
เสื้อยืดใช่มก็มีแค่เสื้อตัวเดียวจริงๆ
ถ้าอากาศร้อนเนี่ยฤดูร้อนถ้าคุณนิกอยู่
บ้านนะคุณนิกอาจจะไม่ใส่เสื้อใส่แค่
กางเกงขาสั้นอยู่ที่บ้านเพราะมันอากาศ
ร้อนเวลาอยู่ที่ไทยอ่ะครับ
อืนะก็เลยเลือกฤดูหนาวใช่มั้ยคะหนาวใช่
ใช่อ่ะข้อที่ 2 นะคะครูนิกครูนิครับอยาก
จะเลือกอะไรมากกว่ากันระหว่าง a  a นะคะ
ให้ครูนิกเนี่ยไปอนาคตตอนนี้เนี่ยมันปี
2022 ครับใช่มตอนนี้นะ 2022 แต่ a เนี่ย
ให้ครูนิกไปอนาคตก็คือปี
2000  72 แล้วกันไปอนาคตซัก 50 ปีครับอื
ไปอนาคต 50 ปีนะคะหรือว่าบีให้ครูนิก
เนี่ยกลับไป
อดีตตอนนี้เนี่ย
2022 แต่ให้ครูนิกไปอดีตซัก 100 ปีอืก็
คือ
19  22 นะคะครูนิกจะเลือกอะไรมากกว่ากัน
ระหว่างไปอนาคตที่แบบไม่รู้จะเป็นยังไง
หรือว่าไปอดีต 100 ปีที่แล้ว
อือือันนี้เลือกยากหรือเลือกง่ายอันนี้
จริงๆแล้วก็เลือก
ง่ายทำไมคูนิเป็นคนเลือกง่ายอ่ะมันไม่
ต้องคิดเยอะเลยไม่ต้องคิดเยอะใช่คือจริงๆ
แล้วมันเหมือนกับเกมอันเนี้ยครับมันก็
เป็นคำถามที่คุณนิกกับเพื่อนเนี่ยก็เล่นๆ
กันมาบ้างใช่มันก็สดุกใช่แต่ทีนี้มันก็
คือถ้าให้เลือกคครูนิกเนี่ยระหว่างอนาคต
กับอดีตค่ะอืคครูนิกอ่ะจะเลือกอนาคต
หืทำไมอ่ะคะครูนิกเลือก a เนาะใช่
ทำไมคือครุณนิคิดว่าอนาคตเนี่ยมันน่าตื่น
เต้นมากกว่าอ๋อเพราะว่าเราไม่รู้ว่ามัน
เป็นยังไงใช่ใช่แต่ถ้าเราเลือกอดีตเนี่ย
คือเรากลับไปในอดีตเราก็รู้อยู่แล้วว่า
อดีตมันเป็นแบบเนี้ยอืแล้วมัน
ก็ไปทำอะไรไม่ได้เพราะมันเป็นสิ่งที่เรา
รู้อยู่แล้วมันเคยเกิดขึ้นมาแล้วมันก็เลย
ทำให้คิดว่าออนาค
น่าตื่นเต้นมากกว่าอืเพราะว่าเราแบบเอ๊ปี
2072 จะเป็นยังไงนะเราจะเป็นยังไงใช่โลก
จะเป็นยังไงไทยจะเป็นยังไงอแบบเอ๊ปี
2072 ประเทศไทยน้ำท่วมอยู่
มยคุณนี้คะ 100 ปีที่แล้ว
1922 ประเทศไทยก็น้ำท่วมค่ะเห็นมั้ย
เพราะฉะนั้นอีก 50 ปีข้างหน้าูหญิงคิดว่า
น้ำท่วมแน่นอนก็ยังท่วม
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
อยู่โอเคพอสมมุติไปอนาคตใช่มเอ๊ะอยากรู้
ประเทศไทยน้ำท่วมมยพอไปถึงอนาคตเห็นน้ำ
ท่วมแล้วก็คิดเอ๊ะอันนี้อนาคตหรือยังอยู่
ปัจจุบันทำไมเหมือนเดิมใช่หรือว่าไปอดีต
อดีตหรือเปล่า 100 ปีที่แล้วหรือเปล่าคิด
ว่าไม่เปลี่ยนนะคะไม่เปลี่ยนอ่ะโอเคข้อ
ต่อไปนะคะครู
นิกอันนี้ให้เลือกดูดูนะครูนิกจะอยากจะ
เลือกดูอะไรมากกว่ากันนะคะ
ระหว่างดูพลุนะเดี๋ยวครูหญิงเปิดรูปให้ดู
นะคะเนาะ
อเดี๋ยวขอปรับหน้าครูแป๊บนึงนะคะดูพลุนะ
คะอ่าดูพลุนะอืหรือ
ว่าดูละคร
เวทีครับเป็นละครเพลงด้วยเนาะร้องเพลงนะ
คะครับครูนิกจะเลือกดูอะไรอยากจะเลือก
อะไรมากกว่ากันระหว่างละครเวทีหรือว่าดู
พลุออื
[เพลง]
อืครู
นิกจะเลือกละครเวที
อืปกติครูนิกชอบดูพลุมั้ยคะชอบดูพลุมั้ย
ชอบมั้ย
ออครูนิใช้คำว่าเฉยๆะกันอืก็คือดูดก็ได้
ไม่ดูก็ได้โอเคใช่เพราะก็ไม่ได้ตื่นเต้น
ที่พอเห็นพุแล้วว่าอุยพลุสวยพอคิดว่า
เอ่อก็โอเค
อ่าเข้าใจเข้าใจผู้หญิงก็คิดเหมือน
กันครับแต่ว่าละครเวทีเนี่ยมันตื่นเต้น
มากกว่าใช่มั้ยคะใช่มันตื่นเต้นมากกว่า
แล้วมันก็คือละครเวทีเนี่ยบางบางอันมันก็
เป็นเรื่องที่เราเคยดูแล้วแต่ว่าคนที่
เล่นละครเวทีเนี่ยไม่ใช่คนเดิมตลอด
อืใช่ี้ใช่มั้ยคะก็จะเปลี่ยนไปเออเนาะคือ
จริงๆเก็เล่นไม่เหมือนกันจริงๆเนี่ยมัน
เปลี่ยนคือยกตัวอย่างสมมุติปีนี้เป็นคน
นี้อีก 2 ปีมาเล่นใหม่ก็อาจจะเป็นคนใหม่
แบบเอือ่าอ่าโอเคค่ะอ่ะข้อต่อไปนะคะข้อ
ต่อไปเนี่ยก็เกี่ยวกับฤดูร้อนฤดูหนาวโอเค
ข้อแรกเนี่ยครูหญิงให้ครูนิกเลือกว่าอยาก
ให้ฤดูร้อนหรือฤดูหนาวมากขึ้นหรือว่านาน
ขึ้นใช่มั้ยคะข้อนี้เนี่ยให้ครูนิกเนี่ย
เลือกระหว่างครูนิกอยากจะเลือกอะไรมาก
กว่ากันระหว่างให้ครูนิกกินซอสเผ็ดในฤดู
ร้อนอันนี้คือแบบเผ็ดมากนะคะสมมุตินะคะคุ
หญิงก็ไม่รู้ว่าอันนี้เผ็ดหรือเปล่านะใน
อากาศเนี่ยอ่ะ 40 องเซซร้อนแล้วก็กินซอส
เผ็ดแเผ็ดใช่ค่ะหรือว่าครูนิอยากจะเลือก
นี้ก็ได้กิน
ไอศครีมในฤดูหนาวเอาหนาวมากๆแล้วกันเท่า
ไหร่ดีที่บ้านครูนิกอ่ะค่ะที่เมืองที่ครู
นิกอยู่หนาวมากๆเท่าไหร่ประมาณเท่าไหร่คะ
เออประมาณติด
ลบ 20 องศ
เซซอ้าวล
20 กินไอศกรีมในอากาศ -2 องเซซหรือว่า
อุ้ยกินซอสเผ็ดในอากาศ 40  10 องศเซซครู
นิกเลือกอะไร
คะ
อืมถ้าครูนิกต้องเลือกเนี่ยอือครูนิจะ
เลือกอะไรมากกว่ากันครูนิกจะเลือกกินซอส
เผ็ดในฤดูร้อนทำไมอ่ะคะ
คือจริงๆแล้วเนี่ยครูนิกเนี่ยทำทั้ง 2
อย่างมาแล้วอ๋อก็คือกินไอศกรีมในอากาศ
หนาวมากๆก็ทำแล้วก็ทำแล้วแล้วก็ซอสพริกก็
ทำแล้วคือซอสพริกเผ็ดๆเนี่ยจริงๆแล้วก็
คืออยู่
ที่ประเทศไทยแล้วก็ไปกินส้มตำกับเพื่อน
เออคือครูนิกเนี่ยเป็นคนกินเผ็ดเพื่อนคู
นิกก็กินเผ็ดมันก็เลยพอกินอะไรเผ็ดๆในอ
อากาศร้อนคุณนิกรู้สึกว่าคุณนิกชอบอัน
นั้นมากกว่าเพราะว่ามันน่ามันน่าตื่นเต้น
มากกว่าูนิกเลือกทุกข้อเพราะว่าตื่นเต้น
เอ้าแต่ว่ากิน
ไอศแล้วกินไอศครีมในฤดูหนาวแบบอากาศหนาว
มากเนี่ย-บ 20 ไม่ตื่นเต้นเหรอคะว่าแบบ
เอกินเสร็จแล้วเราจะ
แบบแข็งไปเลยรือเปล่า
มันมันก็จริงๆตอนแรกก็คิดแบบนั้นแต่ทีนี้
พอทำแล้วก็รู้สึกว่าอืก็ไม่นี่อ๋อก็ก็
โอเคมันก็กินได้เนาะหนาวกินไอศกรีมมันรู้
สึกปกติธรรมดาธรรมดาแต่ว่าร้อนกินส้มตำ
เผ็ดๆคือบ้านเรามีส้มตำที่มันเผ็ดมากๆมัน
รู้สึกแบบโหเเไปมันแบบโอโอ้ย
แซ่บใช่ๆๆ
ๆข้อสุดท้ายนะคะครูนิกครูนิกจะเลือกอะไร
มากกว่ากันระหว่างถ้าปีหน้าปี 20  23 นะ
คะ
วัน
นะใน 365 วันเนี่ยครูนิกต้องใส่ชุดนอนทุก
วันครับอืหรือว่าครูนิอาจจะอยากเลือกอัน
นี้ก็ได้นะคะให้ครูนิกใส่ชุด
คอสตูมทุกวันอ่ะตัวนี้ก็ได้ชื่อตัวอะไร
ไม่รู้มันน่ารักดีนะคะ
ครับใส่ชุดคอสตูมหรอหรือชุดนอนอันนี้คือ
ใส่ออกไปข้างนอกหรือแค่ใส่นอนอย่างเดียว
ใส่ไปข้างนอกด้วยค่ะก็คือใส่ทุกวันน่ะไป
ไหนก็ต้องใส่ชุดนี้คูนิกจะเลือกใส่พวกชุด
คอสตูมหรือว่าชุด
นอนคครูนิกเนี่ยครุณนิกจะเลือกชุดคอสตูม
หะคุณจะใส่ชุดนี้ไปทำงานเหรอคะครับใช่
ทำไม
อ่ะคือครูดิ๊กอ่ะคิดว่าถ้าใส่ชุดนอนเนี่ย
เพื่อนๆเพื่อนเนี่ยก็จะคิดว่าเอ้าชุดนอน
แสดงว่าตื่นสายแล้วมาใช่มย
อ่าไม่มีเวลาเปลี่ยนชุดแต่ถ้าเป็นชุด
คอสตูมเนี่ยคนก็จะคิดว่าอ๋อเาซื้อชุดอัน
นี้มาเพื่อใส่ก็อถ้าไปทำงานเพื่อนก็อาจจะ
คิดว่าออสงสัยคงชอบคอสตูมมั้งก็เลยใส่
คอสตูมมาทำงาน
อืก็เลยเลือกใส่ชุดคอสตูมแล้วถ้าเลือกใส่
ชุดคอสตูมครูนิจะใส่ชุดอะไรคะคิด
มั้ยชุดอะไรอรอจริงๆชุดอะไรก็ได้เลยนะ
เพราะว่าไม่ได้มีเออชุดอะไร Power  Ranger
อะไรอย่างงี้ได้ใช่มั้ยคะอุลตร้าแมนสอร์
Man ใช่ได้หมดเลยเป็นชุดแบบพวก
ซุปเปอร์ฮีโร่ก็ได้อืค่ะอืเนาะก็อันนี้ก็
เป็นเกมนะคะให้ครูนิกว่าเอ๊ะจริงๆครูนิก
อาจจะไม่อยากเลือกทั้ง 2 ก็ได้นะแต่ว่า
ครูนิกจะเลือกอะไรมากกว่ากันเนาะส่วน
วีีดีโอนี้ก็ครูหญิงกับครูนิกก็ไปก่อนนะ
คะโอเคครับหมดเวลาแล้วไว้เจอกันใหม่ครั้ง
ต่อไปได้ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
ครับ